[Musique]
bruno retailleau le président des
sénateurs les républicains également le
président du parti forces républicaines
le parti que vous avez hérité de
françois fillon n'est ce pas pour nous
retailleau est notre invité bonsoir
c'est un mouvement plutôt que c'est un
mouvement on va dire laboratoire d'idées
bonsoir à vous merci en tous les cas à
vous d'avoir invité accepté l'invitation
des chaînes parlementaires de public
sénat de lcp assemblée nationale du
figaro et de l' afp les internautes qui
nous suivent sur le site du figaro
peuvent bien sûr réagir comme chaque
semaine via le chat alors je me ferais
bien sûr l'interprète de vos
interpellations avec moi d'emblée sur ce
plateau pour la première partie paulo
bria yves thréard merci messieurs
bonsoir
le député la république en marche au
aurélien attachés et le sénateur
socialiste david assouline que vous
connaissez bien seront là dans une
vingtaine de minutes pour dialoguer et
également vous interpeller pour nos
hôtes ayo puis dans la dernière partie
d'émission nous rejoindront au
rayonnement de chimie et brigitte
boucher des chaînes parlementaires qui
vous interrogions notamment bien sûr ce
livre votre livre programme livre qui
est titré refondation qui est un livre
réquisitoire pour emmanuel macron on
peut le dire quand même il ya des pages
c'est vers un livre réquisitoire
également pour une partie de vos amis de
la droite il faut le dire également
refondations pour vous qui passez par
l'identité et la liberté la liberté et
l'identité
on aura l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure la première partie donc avec mes
confrères du figaro et de la fp bruno
retailleau le ton s'est durci évidemment
après que le sénat a adressé à la
justice le dossier des collaborateurs
les plus proches du chef de l'état est
ce que vous redoutez aujourd'hui des
représailles de l'exécutif est ce que
vous imaginez que on reparle du côté du
pouvoir de la suppression du sénat par
exemple évidemment que non je leur dit
pas du tout puisque il serait facile à
ce moment là de dire qui mêle makrouds
se venge sur le sénat et il ne le fera
pas bien sûr ce chef de l'état il est le
garant de nos institutions
simplement j'ai observé et j'invite
d'ailleurs tous les commentateurs tous
les observateurs les journalistes à
faire un travail que j'ai fait ce
week-end à reprendre la chronique des
réponses et des réactions des vals
macron mais aussi de la macro ni depuis
le début du déclenchement de cette
affaire jusqu'à maintenant et on va voir
que
les réactions d'abord c'est on minimise
n'y a pas d'affaires s'est élevé à craon
l'avait dit une affaire d'état une
affaire d'été ou même il avait même dit
c'est une tempête dans un verre d'eau
voilà et puis après il ya la
dramatisation donc tantôt on veut
minorée et ensuite on dramatise non je
vais vous dire une seule chose pour que
les téléspectateurs comprennent bien
nous avons il ya un an au sénat à la
suite d'une commission denquête où nous
avions établi la preuve qu'un professeur
de médecine qui a sans doute d'ailleurs
sauvé des vies humaines d'optymo logis
avait sans doute menti sous serment et
nous avons pris une décision grave de le
déférer devant la justice
il a été sanctionné et il a été
sanctionné alors est ce que parce que et
au prétexte qu'il s'agissait de colas
batwa de collaborateur de l'elysée des
mâles macron il fallait pas suivre la
neige la même je ris pris ça va ça va
aller jusqu'au bout parce que c'est
quand même grave si vous voulez c'est de
pouvoir législatif qui civis dans
l'organisation interne de l'elysée vous
allez bien vous avez un pouvoir de
contrôle
pourquoi vous les avez renvoyé enfin
pourquoi vous avez demandé à la justice
en l'occurrence au ministère public de
se saisir de ce dossier des trois
collaborateurs
parce que vous avez la conviction qu'ils
ont menti devant la commission denquête
je veux d'abord dire c'était le premier
temps de votre question que si le sénat
est allé vérifier les services de
sécurité de l'elysée c'est pas pour
vérifier les services du président de la
république c'est parce que ses services
de sécurité sont sous l'autorité du
ministère de l'intérieur
et donc c'est notre plein droit
constitutionnel deuxième chose c'est
tout simplement parce que nous avons
constaté que mois de juillet lorsque
nous avons auditionné ces trois
collaborateurs
la même question leur a été posée est ce
que monsieur benalla avait t'il une
mission notamment en matière de sécurité
les trois ont répondu non et lorsque
nous avons eu la note de service
quelques mois ensuite après il a fallu
il a demandé à plusieurs reprises nous
sommes aperçus que non seulement ils
avaient une mission qui concernait la
sécurité mais qu'il coordonnait les
services de sécurité et d'ailleurs
j'observe c'est est paru dans un
quotidien ou moins juillet que lors de
sa ils comment dirais-je son audition
par rapport à la police judiciaire de sa
garde à vue
monsieur biya avait déclaré
nous avons le savoir qu'il aurait
demandé de mentir aussi non non non
attendez simplement on est on a une
constitution c'est tout on a des
institutions
aujourd'hui il ya une
hyperprésidentialisation très bien mais
il faut aussi de quelques contre-pouvoir
c'est tout j'en déduis qu'ils ont menti
donc ses trois collaborateurs
ce n'est pas à nous de le dire nous
pensons que nous avons réunis c'est
votre avis pour exercer notre intime
conviction
c'est pas à nous de condamner nous ne
sommes pas nos regards jeu de jugement
alors là du coup on ferait on
enfreindrait cette fois de séparation
puisque c'est à la justice de dire si
oui présent pour alors et on a
l'impression qu'au sénat tout le monde
était pas forcément très favorable à ce
que ces cas soient transmis à la justice
notamment le cas du président gérard
larcher
est ce que c'est vous qui avait forcé la
main c'est ce que d'aucuns suppose
suppute gérard larcher n'était pas très
enclin au départ à transmettre à la
justice s'est calmé gérard larcher dans
ces moments là doit être sur une retenue
il est président d'institution c'est le
deuxième personnage de la république
mais croyez-moi il a voté le rapport
proposé par valérie létard qui était
d'ailleurs une centriste et quand on
voit le nombre de sénateurs qui étaient
autour de la table à une écrasante
majorité
donc s'il y avait eu des soupçons des
doutes très très forts croyez-moi chose
ce sera les humeurs après parce qu'il ya
le président de l'assemblée nationale
qui devait tenir conférence un deal avec
le président du sénat kelly bastien
comme ça moi j'y vais pas et le
président le premier ministre et dit je
ne vais pas aux questions du
gouvernement au sénat
il ya une crise quand même entre le
sénat et le pouvoir exécutif péripéties
où la majorité présidentielle c'est de
l'amour hisser la péripétie savez
monsieur monsieur référendum lui non moi
je les paye je sais que gérard larcher
est allé gérard larcher est allé à
sciences po lille ont été excessivement
bien reçue par les méchants sport tout
ce qu'ils ont considéré quand même leur
faire payer par l'absence du président
de l'assemblée nationale qui cite est
engagée que tout ça d un peu loin je
trouve avant et vous alors que vous
pensez de son absence aux questions
d'actualité est ce qu'elle sait à quel
accueil vous
réservez demain lors de son retour mais
un accueil habituelle avant mais il n'y
a aucun problème
nous nous rendîmes un avion à répondre à
une question nous avions réuni des
indices qui nous faisait penser qu' il y
avait paru en tout cas que une partie de
la vérité avait été dissimulée malgré
tout on avait d'ailleurs vivement les
relations entre le sénat et la
présidence de la république
il y avait une espèce d'accord tacite
entre gérard gachet et le président pour
ne pas toucher au sénat dont des futures
réformes constitutionnelles est-ce que
c'est caduque
est ce que les institutions je suis
désolé c'est pas du bricolage c'est pas
un marchandage passement le 7e passe
asséné que c'est non c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne nous sommes comptables
une constitution et je pense que on a
des règlements qui est une
hyperprésidentialisation de la vème
république
pas seulement d'ailleurs depuis mails
macron l'assemblée nationale vous savez
très bien
elle ne peut plus jouer ce rôle de
séparation des pouvoirs
parce que la séparation entre l'exécutif
et l'assemblée nationale c'est plus
possible la démocratie je voudrais
redire si vous me le permettez michel
grossiord c1 le suffrage universel mais
ça n'est pas que ça si ça n'était que ça
monsieur erdogan serait un très grand
démocrate c'est aussi la séparation
l'assemblée nationale n'est plus en
mesure de tenir la dragée haute à
l'elysée c'est à dire de faire c'était
étanchéité pour con parce qu'elles
étaient également alignés et parce que
c'est le jour où quelqu'un le nom et non
parce que avec vous incrire l'occasion
exactement avec lequel ankara avec
quinquennat vous avez une sorte de
réplique sismique c'est à dire que et en
plus avec les en marche les gens
n'étaient pas connues les députés ils
accrochaient leurs photos avec à côté de
la photo des mails macron et ils ont été
lus si j'ose dire par procuration donc
ça exagéré et vous avez raison de le
dire un tour qui était le fait
majoritaire dans le sacré publie donc
tirons-en les conséquences le sénat qui
n'est pas élu sur le memri avec les
mêmes électeurs et même calendrier
il lui revient aussi de faire respecter
un certain nombre de principes mais
calmement et encore une fois on n'a pas
commencé à déférer à la justice pour les
commission denquête les collaborateurs
de monsieur macron on a commencé avec un
professeur de médecine il ya un an peut
évoquer la réforme
la constitution via un instant et vous
dans votre livre bruno retailleau vous
explique en fait que cette réforme a dès
l'origine avaient eux mêmes c'est le
maquereau nisme qui avaient des origines
comme objectif d'affaiblir l'opposition
parlementaire vous le dit hein vous
dites c'est une démagogie anti
parlementaire donc je repose la question
de tout à l'heure en fait est-ce que
vous aujourd'hui avec cette affaire
benalla et ses suites est ce que vous
demandez au chef de l'état d'éclaircir
ses ambitions concernant le sénat
notamment ses attentions sinon c'est
ambitieux que j'ai simplement qu est ce
que vous demandez au châble de par les
institutions ne peuvent pas être le bouc
émissaire des problèmes que la france
ait connu c'est trop facile de se
reporter sur les questions
institutionnelles et de ne pas régler
les questions de fond que je pense que
il ya le grand débat il est maintenant
terminée dans sa première phase une
deuxième phase a commencé et il va
falloir le conclut accords conclus
précisément baudroie décision il ya
quand même il y avait une volonté
présidentielle de faire une réforme
institutionnelle
il ya effectivement des questions
d'ordre institutionnel qui se posent à
l'intérieur du grand débat qui sont pas
majoritaires et qui sont pas au haut de
la pile on va dire néanmoins compte tenu
de l'attitude du sénat
rien ne peut se faire comme réforme des
institutions sans que le ces droits
soient partie prenante
est ce que c'est possible est ce que à
votre avis le président de la république
va s'engager dans cette réforme
je pense que c'est possible parce que
vous avez une lecture très événementiel
vous accrocher un instant l'instant
c'était la semaine dernière une décision
du bureau du bureau du sénat et crise
politique institutionnelle le premier
ministre le présente assemblée
etc etc mais quand vous regardez de plus
près le comportement du sénat vous
verrez que nous avons nous avons voté
plus de textes de lois qui nous ont été
soumis par le gouvernement que nous n'en
avons refusé je me souviens même
d'ailleurs le 21 au 22 décembre en
quelques jours nous avons été capables
de faire passer le paquet gilet jaune
des 11 milliards
monsieur macron avait explicité le 10
décembre dernier face aux bills forme et
parce que j'aime la vie de vos
prérogatives et si jamais
par exemple on diminue le nombre de
sénateurs vous êtes d'accord on a
toujours une ligne constante
on a dit c'est pas la loi du nombre on
veut simplement que nos territoires les
plus fragiles ceux qui ont perdu leurs
instituteurs leur facteur leur commerce
qui ne sont leurs médecins soient
représentés justement donc on ne veut
pas d'un chiffre de 30% parce qu alors
là vous avez près de la moitié des
départements qui n'ont plus qu'un
parlementaire notamment à un sénateur et
du coup on peut plus être dans la
proximité or le mouvement des gilet
jaune à bel abbès que combien de ce
moteur puisque vous êtes pour la baisse
de sénateurs voulaient que nous avons
toujours indiqué qu'il fallait le moins
possible de départements chiffres avec
autour de faim mais je veux dire que on
peut du département je veux dire que 30%
c'est du fétichisme du nombre et il faut
trouver la bonne réduction qui permettra
à la fois de réduire ça réglera aucun
problème entre nous mais faut qu'on
arrive à part la rue urbaine en fait non
non il doit y avoir une juste
représentation
voilà surtout et je pense que la juste
représentation c'est important notamment
pour la france périphérique
c'est une des grandes leçons et combien
de sénateur en moins à discuter mais on
n'est pas fermés du tout d'accord non
mais alors alors paul bru de retail vous
parler précisément des gilets jaunes
vous êtes auteur en d'autres guillemets
delà de la loi anti casseurs qui n'est
pas encore en vigueur puisqu'elle fait
l'objet d'un examen devant le conseil
constitutionnel
pour autant on s'est rendu compte qu'il
ya d'autres dispositifs déjà existants
qui ont permis de limiter la casse entre
guillemets samedi dernier est-ce que du
coup votre loi a encore eu un intérêt
une légitimité
on peut très bien s'en tirer sans est la
casse était limitée samedi pourquoi
parce qu on a interdit notamment
précisément des secteurs dans certaines
villes de france aux manifestants c'est
pas pour ça que la cassette et glitters
la casse étaient limitées parce que les
casseurs sont pas pu voyager simplement
je veux simplement faire remarquer que
sans doute que de temps en temps
l'interdiction de manifester peut-être
le dernier recours mais avec mon texte
ce que je voulais moi justement c'est
éviter ce genre de mesure et venir c'est
prévenir c'est interdire à ceux qui
cassent à ceux qui propagent la haine
anti-flic donc la haine de la république
à ceux qui payent de prévenir et
justement de les écarter eux il faut les
interdire de manifestations pour ne pas
avoir un interdire de manifester
à ceux qui veulent manifester
pacifiquement être votre projet qui est
repris en grande partie par le
gouvernement quand même faut l'admettre
est un antidote justement à ce genre de
masque on aura ce à quoi on a le dilemme
soit les black blocks
on s'en occupe et on s'en occupe
fermement pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des
suites judiciaires qui sont si faibles à
peu près 5% entre les écrits condamné
l'attitude de la justice n'est pas assez
ferme dans ses comptes vient justement
ce que je veux dire c'est que on a un
souci c'est que dans le droit pénal
vous devez pour condamner les gens
établir un lien direct entre l'identité
et la commission de l'acte le problème
c'est quand les gens sont cagoulés
qu'ils ont en plus ils peuvent se
changer en quelques dizaines de secondes
d'andy maintenant et bien maintenant
quand la loi voilà on règle le problème
et les cagoules et on les embarque et on
leur interdit de manifester et ceux qui
trouvent que ce texte liberticide
je pense qu'au contraire il préserve la
liberté de manifester pacifiquement
qu'est ce que vous auriez donné
également un conseil d une leçon de
sagesse cette manifestante c'est un gène
her2 nysc chute est manifestement qui
n'a pas eu de contact avec les forces de
l'ordre c'est ce que dit le procureur
aujourd'hui
qui a été quand même blessé à l'hôpital
et qui était dans une zone interdite et
qui était dans une zone interdite je le
pressens premier conseil site contient
une zone interdite hume effet c'est sur
internet c'est de ne pas braver
l'interdiction est d'accord avec red
bull n'a par contre par contre est un
canular quand ce que je voudrais dire
aimer le maquereau on sait que qu'ils
arrêtent avec les petites phrases qu'ils
arrêtent de jeter de l'huile sur le feu
parce que on voit bien que ça hystérise
on est dans un moment où la france est
profondément désuni et je pense que le
rôle du chef de l'état n'est pas une
petite phrase sur tel ou tel cas
individuels ça ne peut que le desservir
et surtout ça ne peut que des visées de
pays et on n'a pas besoin de ça c'est
pas nouveau puisque on assistait aussi à
l'épisode notre-dame-des-landes
d'aujourd'hui pendant que nous parlons
une région une ville que vous connaissez
bien qui s'appelle le mans est mise à
feu et à sac par et bien des forains qui
manifeste qui s'en sont pris à la mairie
qui sont il n'y a pas une espèce
aujourd'hui de délitement de l'autorité
publique que vous constatez où tout
commence à nos trains des landes et vous
pourriez reprendre un certain nombre
d'enregistrements que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs en partie dans ses studios
mais dans d'autres studios et à l'époque
j'avais dis attention
le signal de l'abandon de l'autorité de
l'état ce sera un film un signal funeste
pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
notre dame des landes
on a donné raison aux ultra violent
contre la démocratie contre une
consultation publique contre 179
décisions de justice contre la
démocratie représentative droite et
gauche
nous étions tous d'accord pour que cette
région ou dans les musées que la
démocratie est en danger
j'en déduis que mails macron a commis
son péché originel en matière d'autorité
de l'état à notre nom des gens parce que
alors ça a été interprété qu'elles sont
très simples en disant si vous mettez en
échec l'ordre républicain
alors vous pourrez vous exonérer un
moment ou un autre du respect de la loi
commune
voilà le message il est là et il a été
entendu ce message
croyez moi ça veut dire comment on sort
aujourd hui de la crise au social
politique avec ce grand débat rallonge
quel est ce que d'abord est-ce que c'est
derrière nous est ce que au contraire
vous pensez que ça va s'empirer et
comment on fait à moi j'espère que ça va
s'empirer
je pense qu'il faut à la fois maintenir
l'ordre républicain j'avais d'ailleurs
déposer des textes anti casseurs
à l'époque c'est bien avant le gilet
jaune c'était sécurité sur les
considérations sociales politiques sur
quelle réponse à donner à ce mouvement
des gigas jaune au delà une réponse
d'abord politique et je ne vois pas je
ne vois pas un retour au calme sans un
retour aux urnes à sa dissolution
non ça veut dire ça peut vouloir dire un
référendum à faire alors je ne vois pas
comment vous sortez de cette crise sans
doute sa parole hrw offensant redonner
la parole aux façades constitutionnel
législatif est ce qu'il faut un petit
peu et donner aux justement la
progression lidl
pardon quelles propositions quelqu'un
qui y assurent non mais c'est pas moi
c'est aux prisons de république
ouais je pense qu on doit sortir du
grand débat avec moins d'impôts
certainement pas avec plus un pot avec
tel ou tel ou tel qu'atos poser la
question augmentation du chemin et que
la majorité va dire oui ou non
ah non mais moi je sais c'est pas mal
c'est par un projet à écouter moi je
vais la réponse alors qu'est ce que vous
proposez moi moi je pense pardon
fondation indique par exemple en matière
de retraite
on doit poser la question aux français
sa voix sont d'accord j'ai vu j'ai vu
j'ai vu le j'ai eu le sondage du figaro
il n'y a pas de solutions soit est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour paupériser
les aînés c'est à dire c'est qu'il s'est
passé d'ailleurs et belle macro avait
promis pendant sa campagne qui ne
toucherait pas à l'âge de départ
et bien comme ils touchent pas l'âge de
départ il à paupériser les retraités par
la csg mais surtout si par la
désindexation ya pas deux solutions
y'a pas de solutionner l'âge de départ
alors je pense qu'il faut augmenter
progressivement à 65 ans pour que l'on
puisse dégager de la ressource pour
garantir le niveau de vie à la dure de
nos aînés osé cette question-là aux
français vous êtes sûr qu'ils vont vous
donner un désagrément c'est du solide et
je pense que sur l'immigration il ya
aussi une question est ce qu'on peut oui
ou non vous pouvoir faire ensemble que
ce qui l'attend chaque année chaque
année que le parlement va bien et non
pas la rue le parlement puisse désigner
un certain de quotas pour les migrations
je pense que ça fait partie des sujets
qu'on peut parfaitement transmettre aux
français pour qu'ils puissent auditions
des retraites ça va être compliqué quand
même
mais a coûté en tout cas moi j'estime
que les français ont du bon sens et que
si vous leur expliquez qui a ou bien le
choix d'une paupérisation écouter
partout autour de nous on travaille 65
ans jusqu'à 67 ans je pense que c'est
trop mais progressivement ajoutés trois
ans jusqu'en 2025 au à l'âge légal de
départ en retraite
franchement ça permet de garantir le
pouvoir d'achat de nos aînés et ils sont
eux mêmes un bouclier social dans la
famille vis-à-vis des petits enfants
vis-à-vis de leurs propres enfants et en
même temps dire aux français il ya une
énormité aujourd'hui vous avez des
retraites de moins de 1000 euros
faut voir un peu je vis dans les zones
rurales les retraites agricoles mais
c'est rien du tout combien de questions
vous poser dans votre référendum non
mais là peut déjà on avait déjà deux on
a d'autres ce n'est pas moi qui pose
c'est le présent de république qui devra
se réaliser à 6 tours on veut qu'on se
réfère donc forcément après européenne
ou est ce qu'on peut faire avant lorsque
j'ai après reçu par le président de
république
c'était il ya un mois ils recevaient
vous savez le l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires et julien vanni monsieur
le président de grâce de grâce ne jouez
pas les européennes à la roulette russe
ne fait pas un référendum avec les
européennes parce qu'à ce moment là vous
escamoté totalement les européennes
alors là dès qu'il a eu on va déjà avoir
une campagne européenne qui va être
peut-être escamoté parce que je vois
bien cette tentation du pouvoir
d'allonger d'effilocher le grand débat
compris depuis qu'on sait que c'est vrai
que c'est nathalie goisot qui sera tête
de liste devant un public en marche est
ce que ce n'est pas suffisant que tu
sais pas une tête des européennes il ya
une campagne qui a été lancée par le 1er
mai par le président de la république
vous êtes en ordre de bataille également
quasiment tous les partis le son dans sa
lettre qu'il a adressée à tous les
européens
le président de la république a parlé de
souveraineté européenne alors que eh
bien justement actuellement du débat et
bat son plein avec la présence en europe
du président chinois qui vient pour
investir pour acheter pour faire son
marché
est ce que l'europe doit se doter
d'armes suffisamment forte
peut-elle s'en munir contre justement
et bien cette dans cette concurrence
extraits
et que nous livrent des grands pays vous
avez raison de prendre l'exemple du
président chinois qui est ici qui a reçu
par email macron emmanuel macron fait
bien de le recevoir
oui il a absolument le général de gaulle
avait renoué dans une époque autrement
plus difficile avec mao tsé toung avec
la chine c'était il ya 50 si grand
nombre pour lui je ne le conseille pas
et si en plus on vend des airbus et
d'autres choses très bien simplement
simplement je voudrais faire deux
remarques d'une part on est désarmé
juridiquement et politiquement on est
très divisés face à la chine désarmé
juridiquement je regardais inverse la
guerre qui par ailleurs est une bonne
commissaire notamment la concurrence
celle infligée aux gaffes à un certain
nombre de pénalités qui ont coûté très
cher plusieurs milliards elle a refusé
au nom du dogme de la concurrence c'est
un sens puissent avoir un champion du
rail entre siemens et et alstom alors
que on sait très bien que ce scénographe
européens vont devoir lutter contre les
champions chinois
donc voyez que c'est une mauvaise façon
de prendre les choses de européenne la
source le répète jamais ce mot je me
méfie de ce mot une stratégie de
puissance oui mais dans une démocratie
le peuple c'est le souverain or il n'ya
pas un seul peuple en europe tant que
méchant nous et puis on est divisés
politiquement
regardez c'est qui ce qui se passe avec
leur de l'est la pologne la hongrie qui
discute régulièrement avec la chine et
la chine joue de ce bilatéralisme là ne
soyons pas dupes comme elle joue avec
lors du sud notamment avec la grèce avec
l'italie et puis avec le portugal donc
attention on a un empire qui est
absolument sûr de lui et qu'ils
déploient partout dans le monde à
travers ce qu'on appelle la nouvelle
les nouvelles routes de la soie un
nouvel ordre qui sera qui voudrait être
un ordre chinois mais attention c'est un
capitalisme autoritaire il prend le
libre échange mais il ne prend pas les
libertés démocratiques qui
malheureusement trouve dans ce contexte
des partenaires en europe on l'a vu avec
l'italie la grèce mais en avoir
exactement bien alors merci merci
beaucoup monsieur
deuxième partie maintenant d'auditions
publiques avec les deux parlementaires
qui font leur entrée sur ce plateau
david assouline donc à aurélien tâche et
bonsoir messieurs merci beaucoup d'être
là une question d'un internaute du
figaro qui vous demande monsieur
retailleau mais si la justice demain et
bien considère qu'il n'y a pas
d'affaires qu'il n'y a pas de
condamnation dans la sphère benalla
quelle sera la nar est là la position
des sénateurs
1 si la justice classe tout la justice
peut classer plus vous aurez quel film
faire ce qu'elle appelle justice nous on
a constaté qu' il y avait un écart entre
les déclarations et est sans doute la
vérité à un moment donné ils se sont
contredits
c'est désormais à la justice et pas au
sénat de dire il ya vraiment parjure
cette année à la justice d'établir
désormais la réalité des faits voilà
david assouline donc sénateur socialiste
de paris et aurélien tâche et député la
république en marche du val d'oise
peut-être vous avez envie de réagir sur
le david assouline et et moi j'étais pas
au bio parce que les prisons deux
groupes ne sont pas ou la russe elena
beauté moi je suis président du sénat
donc j'étais au bureau je ne vais pas
dévoiler la teneur des délibérations
parce que ça aussi c'est interdit par la
loi mais par contre oui bien sûr que
j'ai voté pour et je pensais qu'on
pouvait pas faire autrement si on
voulait justement ne pas être dans le
jugement politique c'est à dire que j'ai
eu il ya eu 25 interventions nous ont
quand même un peu responsable c'est son
bureau du sénat de nuances différents et
tous ont parlé avec responsabilité
gravité et ou délibéré ont droit et
seulement droit je veux le dire parce
que j'ai entendu aucune interpellation
moi j'espère simplement que voilà avant
de prendre un acte aussi important parce
que c'est pas souvent que la haute
chambre les faire à la justice un
rapport d'une commission denquête chacun
a bien mesuré de quoi il était question
que si vraiment le rapport de la
commission de quatre mois j'ai un petit
peu regardé en ce qu'a écrit valérie
létard il y avait quand même des
éléments assez précis qui disait rien ne
nous permet de dire qu'il ya eu mensonge
un coup de force comme en fin je sais
que bruno retailleau et quelqu'un qui a
voilà la politique qui tient ça pour une
haute idée les institutions aussi le
sénat aussi les valeurs d'autorité
on est dans un pays dans un moment le
pays et quand même fracturé divisé où
tout ce qui peut jeter le discrédit sur
des grands serviteurs de l'état ou sur
des élus doit quand même être vraiment
mesurer au trébuchet donc j'espère
vraiment que vous avez pris toutes ses
précautions et qu'on n'est pas dans
quelque chose de nos politiciens mais je
peux pas penser sa réponse non bien sûr
je redis c'est par ailleurs la
jurisprudence d'ailleurs qu est-ce qu on
aurait pourquoi est ce que un professeur
de médecine qui a sans doute sauvé des
vies humaines alors on arrive au quel
cas de jeunes terminons mettre d'accord
sauf que nous il ya une jurisprudence et
nos institutions doivent fonctionner
quelle que soit la personne qui est en
cause c'est un autre sujet david
assouline
oh non mais le fait de venir devant vous
et même pas gêné non pas politique
exactement c'est la vraie opposition à
ce que je pense sur le plan politique
économique social mais je le reconnais
depuis que je connais bruno retailleau
sénat je sais que il a deux qualités
d'abord il est talentueux deuxièmement
il s'attache toujours aux débats de fond
s'est pas toujours le cas et donc nos
différences elles sont affichées mais il
ya un grand respect ce que je lui
reproche sur le plan politique c'est ce
que j'ai toujours reproché à la droite
et d'ailleurs je constate que il est
obligé souvent de sur jouer son
opposition emmanuel macron parce que
emmanuel macron court derrière ce qu'il
a toujours défendue que ce soit sur les
retraites ou accéder à ce butin qui a
parlé de sa bomba il est d'accord que
les 35 heures c'est un peu passé les
réglementations la dérégulation du du
code du travail il et il est d'accord
sur les actionnaires en moi même il
irait beaucoup plus loin au vu des
macros nettoie sans savoir même quand il
fait une loi sur des questions qui
pourraient le séparait des manuels
macron parce qu'on a cru qu'un manuel
macron était libéral sur le plan
sociétal
quand il propose une loi emmanuel macron
se jettent dessus là roland et la
propose est la vote dès demain non ce
que je reproche c'est qu'il est
c'est qu'il est vis-à-vis des manuels
macron aussi des racques lui et lui
reproche de n'être pas assez seulement
et sur le plan sociétal il lui reproche
d'être trop libéral et donc c'est mais
opposition de fond sur le flanc pas sur
la loi anti-casseurs juste un mot mails
macron est dans la veine du en même
temps 7 quand même inédit que la veille
où le texte passé en deuxième lecture au
sénat le président de république a saisi
le conseil constitutionnel sur un texte
qui venait bien sûr de son opposition
mais qui avait été repris par son
premier ministre et qui avait été amendé
plus durement par son ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est du jamais vu s'est toujours de ces
espèces de balancement et d'ambiguïté en
fait et l'ambiguïté parce que j'imagine
avec le conseil va je pense que le
conseil constitionnel il ne voulait pas
laisser la gauche saisir le conseil
communal
moi je ne vous rejoint pas je pense que
je pense qu on est très différents je
pense que la droite celle que j'incarne
avec le maquereau nice mais très
différente pour moi le maquereau nice si
vous voulez c'est une évolution qui
vient de la gauche d'ailleurs et c'est
pas pour rien qui s'est toujours réclamé
de la gauche aurélien tâche et dyer
faisait partie d'un groupe de gauche
qu'il a milité au parti socialiste et
pour moi c'est pas demander pardon non
écoutés par exemple mais très regardé
très franchement très franchement très
franchement oui parce que les
branchements alors quoi il a vraiment
réformer mélanger ses intestins et je
pense que cette évolution c'est deux
choses c'est un une conversion à une
sorte de mondialisation heureuse un
capitalisme très financier moi je me
suis par exemple proposé adp pour des
raisons de fond la privatisation des
aéroports de par exactement et hanane
hyper individualisme voilà et comoriens
tâche et d'ailleurs il a dit un jour
voilà moi je pense que le libéralisme
soit doit s'étendre aussi sur le champ
culturel
je pense que ça s'est très mal rognant
alors mené là dessus en effet mais non
mais non ccc draper non mais c'est ça je
vis de notre adn n'est pas le même non
bien sûr
moi j'assume je suis sûr de rien d'autre
on n'est pas d'accord sur le prix de la
liberté économique moi je pense que
l'erreur de beaucoup parfois de la
droite aussi c'est d'avoir laissé à
l'extérieur par exemple en europe
très peu de protection notamment
vis-à-vis de nos emplois industriels
l'europe passoire
on est la zone douanière
moins protégé et d'avoir augmenté les
impôts c'est à dire que c'est impossible
d'avoir la liberté à l'extérieur et un
contrôle administratif très avenant mais
très fort à l'intérieur vous avez manqué
des choses ou clairement on est en
totale opposition effectivement et vraie
pensée et vous proposer une pensée
conservatrice qui est complète tout à
fait respectable c'est complètement
pourquoi je vous ai vu un petit peu
d'abord sur la question de l'europe
effectivement on a deux visions qui sont
radicalement opposés
vous considérez que les institutions en
europe ne sont pas le moyen de faire
progresser la démocratie en europe et
qu'il faut revenir à des choses quand on
vous lit entre les lignes qui sont
finalement très intergouvernementale qui
sont très alliance des nations qui sont
pas du tout pour plus d'intégration
européenne là c'est sûr qu'on a une
divergence de fond sur les questions
d'identité
évidemment et qu'est ce que doit être la
france là aussi
moi je plaide et à la république en
marche les progressistes plaide pour une
france ouverte pour une france plurielle
la vision que vous avez délit d'anti
fera tellement je n'y comptais sur
l'immigration familiale économique comme
comme monsieur comme monsieur retailleau
et moi je vous ai déjà différent sur la
cua russes par exemple n'avait même pas
voulu donner non simplement on veut des
règles européennes là dessus aussi c'est
pour ça que en fin jeunes vous savez que
c'est pas vrai s'ils savaient que les
viols et les bateaux ont accosté et
qu'on a pu accueillir des migrants
france qui est le premier pays à le
faire donc c'est faux et même sur les
réformes là aussi vous vous évoquez je
les ai vus le fait que vous n'êtes pas
que conservateur et que vous souhaitez
des réformes mais répondre que vous
proposez c'est pour revenir en arrière
c'est pour régresser sur les droits nous
la réforme des retraites et le retrouve
vous avez parlé de la retraite juste
avant je vous ai écouté vous voulez
reculer l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite proposés sont très tonique
c'est une occasion de redire déclic ce
qu'on voulait c'était une retraite
unique pour tous de la galipette pour
les français mais pas de régresser sur
les bords donc c'est très conservateur
c'est très cohérent et consorts
exprimez revenir sur les droits jamais
un gouvernement n'avait autant matraquer
fiscalement et en termes de pensions
avec la désindexation les retraités
jamais c'est du jamais vu
première chose donc moi je veux
justement que les dirigeants vont
ramener le jeu comprend je comprends
sauf que les retraités ne payent pas de
cotisations salariales c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est parce que nous
avions proposé au monde de la campagne
présidentielle
deuxième chose en matière en matière
d'europe
vous dites vous sépare les institutions
européennes moi ce que je crois
fondamentalement c'est et là il ya une
vraie différence avec allemagne macron
et mal macro et dans la fuite en avant
il le grosso modo l'europe sans la
france c'est à dire que il considère
qu'il ya une souveraineté européenne
très bien et du coup il propose quoi ils
proposent une banque une agence une
espèce de de bureaucratie mais la
bureaucratie
c'est l'anti démocratie et moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il européenne la
démocratie quand la démocratie vive les
mails et des mots que la démocratie vit
dans la nation et c'est quand
regardez par exemple au moment le plus
le plus difficile de la crise européenne
au moment de la crise de l'euro ceux qui
ont sauvé l'euro c'est madame merkel et
nicolas sarkozy c'est pardon c'est pas
la commission parce que la puissance
parce que les gens les peuples quand ça
va mal il se tourne non pas vers des
gens qui sont nommés meilleurs des
régions qui sont tenus moi j'en tire les
conséquences
on peut faire avancer des projets moi je
suis pour une europe avec des
coopérations renforcées
je pense que sur l'énergie je pense que
sur la transition énergétique
je pense que sur l'intelligence
artificielle voilà il ya de bonnes
choses sur les droits voisins david
assouline est un des spécialistes
bon il ya un texte qui va dans le bon
sens mais bien sûr il faut le voter
il ya tant d'autres choses à faire mais
de grâce faisons très attention
quant à la france plurielle et c'est
votre voiture votre vision est celle
d'une identité heureuse votre vision je
suis désolé et celle d'un
multiculturalisme je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la france est très divisé
et je pense que on doit revenir à des
fondamentaux et je pense que la france
multiculturelle c'est une france en peau
de léopard ou vous allez juxtaposer des
communautés non c'est à côté de l'eau
bref la france
une religion et d'une ossature dallas va
dire qu'on ma vie commune ça veut dire
qu'on traite les gens à égalité non mais
ce que je fais ce que je veux dire c'est
que si on veut accueillir l'autre il
faut d'abord être soi même et je pense
que l'identité
il ya l'identité et l'altérité mais il
peut pas y avoir d'altérité
si on n'est pas différent voilà je sens
assez fort et on a demandé après la dga
les cv les français souffrent d'une
angoisse la dépossession identitaire
culturelle
je vais prendre un homme de gauche je
buvais l'insécurité culture est un homme
de gauche si on veut moi je me sens bien
tant mieux c'est de ne plus être eux
mêmes pour accueillir autant plus belle
pour être clair vous parler de la
sécurité face à l'islam
oui non je ne vais voir je pense que les
français ont le pouvoir c'est une
démocratie de dire ce qu'ils peuvent
ceux qui ne veulent pas accueillir sur
le sol air france c'est un principe au
nom et on peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde c'est tout malgré ce que
ça ok ce face à face sur la question de
l'identité et c est assez intéressante
parce qu'en fait vous vous renvoyez
d'une certaine façon à vos propres
incohérences il ya entendu qu'une
république qui combat les communautés y
le république laïque n'est pas une
juxtaposition voile et en même temps
c'est celle que jal doit jeu elle doit
respecter avec légal respect l'ensemble
des populations qui la composent avec
leurs histoires leurs origines etc et
fondre tout cela dans une société
commune avec qui va écrire son histoire
et son identité futur et donc le fait de
pilonner tout le temps de sur vous et le
oui la stigmatisation des musulmans
n'est pas bon pour la nation
de la même façon je comparais auparavant
mais je vous dis que les choses soient
claires dans le positionnement et les
reproches que je peux faire
de la même façon je pense que vous
l'avez regretter après d'avoir comparé
le voile avec un serre tête et quelque
chose d'absolument que le voile est un
outil politique aujourd'hui et on se bat
dans le monde pour pouvoir l'enlever
donc les femmes se battent pour tes
droits donc moi au moins je suis laïque
non communautaires mais ouvert il faut
absolument que comme dans son passé la
france continue est forte et sûre d'elle
même
parce qu'elle accueille parce qu'elle
n'a pas peur de l'autre et dans le monde
actuel et dont l'europe actuelle le
danger y compris pour les malheurs que
je sais que vous partagez le danger
c'est le repli sur soi le nationalement
la xénophobie en europe y compris vos
alliés politiques comme victor hedman
comme nicolas sarkozy s'en est ouvert
bien vu parce que le problème c'est que
la vision d'une société multiculturelle
vous conduit à des approximations je
sais que ça du thé passé sans doute vaut
qu'une sélection sur le serre tête mais
ça ça n'est pas possible je me souviens
de la phrase de monsieur castaner vous
savez sur les lentilles de nos grands
mères c'est la même chose et pour
répondre à des visas solide moi je ne
mets pas en cause les musulmans
simplement il ya un problème avec
l'idéologie de l'islam politique
lorsque monsieur car oui avec l'institut
monteil calcul qui a 28 % près 30% des
français musulmans qui place la charia
au dessus de la loire un public et le
coran au dessus de la constitution
mais fo compliquant mais en désaccord
exactement le problème ne vous entend
pas faire quelque chose et devient
relisez qui devient massifs dans le
monde
l'église évangéliste c'est la leffe et
des élections mais aux etats-unis au
brésil mais voyez nos services
je pense qu'il faut la combattre avec
force donc vous les idées reçues et
lavera d'églises évangéliques est à
mettre sur le même plan
je suis pas du tout et vous allez
certainement mais mais il ya des
endroits vous ne pouvez pas comparer moi
j'étais premier parlementaire en août
2014 suis pas du tout profession
évidemment des confessions je suis allé
en irak mariage pour c'est tout autre gm
à m mais il restait mais arrêtez avec ça
bizarrement en france mais que les ânes
on peut dès maintenant il faut faire
attention aux amalgames simplement le
sait pas le problème des musulmans
simplement il ya un problème avec
l'islam politique qu'il faut bien
d'aller à pied lundi trois et un islam
de france ce n'est pas l'islam politique
sache vous dire parce que vous
considérez qu'il en était de la france
ne peut pas faire de place à l'islam
quel qu'il soit bonne ou non parce que
je catholique pas la qualité avec les
autres professions non le fait de ne pas
justement que j'avais justement que la
même loi de 1905 s'applique avec la même
rigueur pour toutes les religions et je
veux simplement que la même loi
s'applique à 6 à l'islam aussi bien qu'à
la religion mon frère de position et
l'islam est inquiet sur l'islam de
france
ce sera un échec pourquoi parce que
bricoler un islam de france par le haut
ça ne marchera pas pourquoi parce que
huit ou neuf français musulman de
confession musulmane donc sur dix sont
sunnites tonka pas d'église et vous
risquez justement d'enfreindre cette
grande loi de la neutralité de l'état et
franchement avec la france a le droit et
que tout de suite à elle se dit que ne
veut pas du simple volonté on comprend
bien ce que ça veut dire c'est que la
volonté depuis slam devant reyes et de
derry cette religion n'a pas sa place de
la même manière de la région catholique
non mais la folie face à dallas pour peu
qu'elle mais attendez la religion
musulmane comme les autres elle à leur
place elle a sa place pour peu que l'on
respecte la laïcité à la française
revenir à égalité la fraternité comme
les autres questions économiques
peut-être cetc des contradictions aussi
la venue de bruno retailleau une
contradiction important dans ce grand
libéralisme que vous prenez je prends ce
nom votre prochain livre
avouez que c'est un un divertissement
enraciné libéralisme à la lige employés
la contradiction c'est une question
c'est que vous reprochez le laxisme de
la gauche au maitien de sécurité là et
c'est la loi la loi retailleau etc et
vous fermez les yeux sur le fait que
dans votre politique le fait de vouloir
supprimer autant de postes de
fonctionnaires a fait d'ailleurs que
nicolas sarkozy vous avez pas dire un
mot à ce moment-là à supprimer 9000
emplois de policiers qui servirait un
peu plus que votre toit pour faire
connaître l'ordre dans le pays avec son
maintien lors et vous prévoyez encore
plus qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron il
l'a dit 120000 je crois que fillon
disait 500000 peut-être vous avez
chiffré quelque chose maintenant
mais de toute façon il y aura mois de
policiers avec vous qu'il y aura moins
de professeurs efforts et ce sont les
piliers n'est autre que la république m
la réponse non mais il faut dire aux
français il faut avoir le langage de la
vérité je crois on est champion du monde
occidental de la dépense publique oui ou
non c'est vrai et on a justement aussi
on est champion du monde et champion
d'europe de la fiscalité c'est tout et
si on veut rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux
français
il faudra mais le point des policiers
c'est pas il faut des policiers qu'ils
soient dans la rue il faut pas des
policiers derrière marché c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça est ce que vous
savez justement parce que alors vous
avez avec notamment vous avez encouragé
vous avez encouragé la gauche un axe
isme judiciaire 5% des délinquants sont
à l'origine de 50% des actes ne savait
pas ce moment dans les policiers s'ils
ne sont pas souvent assez nombreux c'est
parce que ils ont marre de voir des
désaccords répétés qu'ils arrêtent et
qu'ils retrouvent dans la rue même sur
les manifs
pour conclure dernière question pour moi
bruno retailleau moi j'ai été très
intéressé par le travail que vous avez
entrepris avec votre livre parce que
vous remettez les idées au coeur du
débat politique vous mettez vous
réhabiliter la notion d'idéologie qu'est
en train de se perdre en politique mais
alors petite question comment vous
arrivez à vous sentir heureux dans un
parti dirigé par quelqu'un qui fait
exactement l'inversé qui essaye d'amener
une politique des tripes à la trump qui
essayent finalement en permanence de se
faire passer pour plus imbécile kinect
c'est un garçon intelligent laurent
wauquiez justement parce qu'il considère
jeu vidéo logique
j'ai des gens mais il a peur de
l'admettre et enfin voilà on est quand
même sur l'exacte démarche inverse de
celle que vous prenez qui à mon avis est
la meilleure après on n'est pas d'accord
le débat et s'est attaché vous voulez
vraiment fâché avec toute ma famille
politique ou non je ne sais pas j'ai
fait ça quand ça coûte et moi je trouve
que très franchement le fait d'avoir eu
le courage de nommer françois xavier bel
ami avec notre trio ça montre que au
moins leur wauquiez il est attaché à
cette idée d'une refondation
il faut redonner du sens à l'europe
l'europe comme grandes civilisations et
non pas seulement l'europe comme un
mécanisme institutionnel
quand vous parlez de la droite féodal la
droite potemkine c'est une avance d'un
coup de slogans dans votre année c'est
pas vous qui êtes maintenant c'est pour
moi aussi je veux dire collectivement
nommé collectivement je m'explique vous
n'avez interrogé je m'explique je dis
simplement que la droite depuis
longtemps souvent très impressionné par
les amis de david assouline qui détenait
une sorte d'hégémonie médiatique
idéologique culturelle la droite en
réalité à déserter a déserté le champ
des idées et en désertant le champ des
idées
elle a réinvesti le champ le culte du
chef
tous les médias dans le plat quand vous
terminez messieurs merci on va revenir
sur ce livre justement sur les idées
qu'il contient rien tâches et dans
l'instant ils ont détaché vers son visa
civil ravec au riad mancini à brigitte
boucher qui font leur entrée sur ce
plateau merci beaucoup monsieur merci
oria mais brigitte sont avec nous une
question d'un internaute du figaro bruno
retailleau à propos justement de la loi
de 1905 il n'est plus question désormais
pour le chef de l'état de la réforme et
vous applaudissez avait capoté parce que
j'ai été le premier je crois en tout cas
dans l'arène politique à monter au
créneau à dire que l'islam de france
était une bêtise ça ne permettrait pas
de lutter contre le terrorisme islamiste
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut que
le peuple de francs soit plus unie or
notre union d'autres identités
d'ailleurs c'est aussi la laïcité
il ya un récent sondage qui vient de qui
vient de paraître de la fondation jean
jaurès qui montre que à une écrasante
majorité ne veulent pas qu'on touche à
la loi 1905 mais cet important c'est
notre identité c'est un bien commun
capital commun que nous avons et qui
n'appartient ni à la droite ni à la
gauche ni en marche
je crois que c'est fondamental je pense
que le président république l'a compris
jeu tant de sagesse pour reprendre le
mans il amour il a quand même changé de
pied à quelques reprises rock avec mma
qu'on n'est jamais sûr de rien donc
attendez donc les prochaines
déclarations et pour l'instant il
abandonne la loi de 1905 c'est une bonne
chose et je le dis alors vous n'aurez
tayeau bonsoir vous venez de publier
refondations aux édition de
l'observatoire
vous vous efforcez de redéfinir un idéal
pour la droite pour vous la droite ça
doit être à la fois la liberté et
l'identité libéral sans être libre
échangiste progressiste tout en étant
conservateur c'est un peu votre et en
même temps avoue se refonder ou
s'effacer écrivez vous est ce que la
droite est vraiment à la croisée des
chemins aujourd'hui bien sûr pas que la
droite d'ailleurs pas que la droite est
d'ailleurs la france peut être aussi est
ailleurs qu'en france on a vu ball sonar
où on a vu monsieur trempe on a une
brique site
on a vu ce qui s'est passé en autriche
on a vu ce qui s'est passé en italie
donc il ya un malaise ce malaise il
parcourt le monde en tout cas les
démocraties notamment occidentales il
faut en tenir compte et moi je pense que
le monde a totalement basculé totalement
basculé et que si nous la droite ont
fait pas cet effort pour les français
pas seulement de simples de s'opposaient
mail macro on est l'opposition a bien
mais bien sûr attendait paul-valéry nous
avait appris en 1919
juste après la première guerre mondiale
que les civilisations était mortel si
les civilisations sont mortelles
croyez moi les partis politiques ils le
sont aussi et sans doute à à une vitesse
beaucoup plus grand donc moi je pense
que dans un monde qui bouge et maquereau
a fait bouger les lignes aussi en france
on a nous vis-à-vis des français un
devoir c'est de dire qui on est c'est de
dire qu'est ce qu'on souhaite pour la
france
quel est notre projet quel idéal
français on veut porter l'idéal moi que
je veux porter c'est la politique non
pas comme réduite à l'économie c'est la
politique comme un principe de
civilisation et avec deux jambes la
liberté parce qu'en france on croule
c'est terrible c'est que un des derniers
rapports de la cour des comptes
la cour des comptes écrit que même
l'administration française n'arrive pas
à faire le total du nombre de taxes etc
elle est perdue mais voyez cour des
comptes est incroyable et de la liberté
et l'identité
bien sûr parce que l'identité c'est un
principe que tous les peuples
aujourd'hui réclame quand vous avez en
allemagne par exemple avec un taux de
chômage de moins de 4 % des espèces
d'insurrection électorale c'est parce
que il ya des préoccupations matérielles
mais elles ne sont pas le tout de la vie
d'un peuple les préoccupations
immatériel ce qui tient les fils
invisibles qui nous tiennent notre
héritage de mémoire notre histoire c'est
la volonté de se projeter dans l'avenir
si on a des défis la france moi tu sais
ça que je reproche aussi mm macro et
pour l'instant il ne comprend pas une
la réussite collective c'est pas
seulement la somme des réussites
matériel professionnel individuel
il faut qu'ils parviennent à parler aux
français avec les tripes un peu
gaulliste voilà on est un même peuple
vous non mais ça me ben oui parce que
d'abord ainsi d'un anglicisme et la
langue française elle est belle il faut
vraiment être fiers la langue de
l'olympisme et longtemps la langue de la
diplomatie
la langue française c'est un trésor bon
voilà donc et et surtout face aux défis
qu'on a devant nous si on ne revient pas
un peuple
nous n'aurons pas la volonté de les
relever c'est ce que font certains
sécurité culturelle dont vous parlez
dans votre livre c'est l'une des causes
des montée des populismes en europe et
bien sûr mais bien sûr on a vous savez
cette angoisse je le disais tout à
l'heure dans le débat précédent les
français souffrent d'une double angoisse
ça fait dix ans je le dis le
déclassement économique chômage de masse
l'ascenseur social qui est bloqué vous
avez des enfants ils sont nés dans une
famille modeste
ils ont des handicaps pour leur vie
c'est pas tolérable et puis l'autre
angoisse c'est la dépossession
culturelle cette dépossession culturel
est l'aîné de quoi elle est née de la
jonction que on a fait aux français de
ne plus être eux mêmes pour pouvoir
accueillir l'autre vide et vous de vous
même
d'abord parce que vous avez commis les
crimes contre l'humanité etc
et du coup il faut d'abord que la france
se reconnaissent coupable pour qu'elle
soit aimable mais comment voulez vous
intégrer assimilés deux jeunes français
si vous leur présentez la france comme
coupable de tout voilà où on en est on a
détruit nos héritages
on a détruit nos mails enracinement mais
bien sûr aussi bien sûr quand jacques
chirac voulait pas célébré par exemple
la victoire d'austerlitz bien sûr
évidemment que la droite ya prêté la
main parce que souvent sous les
objurgations de la bien pensante de
dents de gauche vous appelez donc
l'insécurité ainsi que rennes profite
essentiellement aux rassemblement
national qui fait jeu égal mais parce
qu'on a abandonné la gauche et la droite
parce que la gauche abandonné par
exemple parce que son % et nous ont
abandonnés par exemple le fait national
etc
mais il faut pas avoir honte dans votre
livre on voit la philosophie
l'idéologique vous voulez défendre pour
la droite
on voit mal les mesures concrètes que
vous pouvez apporter on a l'impression
que depuis les heures supplémentaires de
nicolas sarkozy n'y a pas eu d'idées
nouvelles à droite vous lirez le
chapitre économique sur l'allier sur la
liberté enraciné gelé un peu développés
tout à l'heure mais je crois que en
france on a eu un énorme fera faire il
ya trop d'impôts dont il ya trop de
dépenses donc par exemple sur les
retraites vous disais que vous étiez pas
dans le côté gestionnaire et pourtant
vous dites ya trop d'ego décédé
non mais je suis en vie qu'est ce que
j'ai dit simplement c'est qu'on ne peut
pas réduire la politique seulement à
l'économie
non mais c'est ce qu'a fait la droite
pendant longtemps vous dites je fais des
propositions je fais une proposition que
ça va être les européennes
je pense qu'ils font totalement inversé
la proche il faut que l'europe se
protège nous protège à ses frontières et
que nous en france on libère on a fait
l'inversé on a oublié
l'europe ne nous protégeait pas c'était
une passoire et en plus en france alors
là du coup c'était le carcan fiscale de
la contrainte administrative ça ne peut
pas marcher
et du coup on a désindustrialisé le
protectionnisme aux frontières
intérieures sectionnistes intelligent
écoutez je m'adresse au président
chinois
quand ils pillent nos brevets quand il
ne veut pas ouvrir un cycle de marché
public mais on lui offre
on ne lui ouvre pas du marché point
final est ce que dans votre approche
vous qui n'avez pas voté en 1982 soit
traité de maastricht est ce que vous
dites on garde quand même le seuil des
3% de déficit public ou pas mais les 3 %
c'est pas un prêt de maastricht les 3%
c'est un problème de bon sens on a des
milliards et des milliards on a de plus
de 2000 milliards d'endettement vous
imaginez les jeunes français ce qu'on va
laisser aux jeunes générations
on va non seulement leur laisser une
planète et que logiquement détériorer on
va leur laisser un monceau de dette sur
les bras et donc ce qui commande le bon
sens commande dondas france le 10ème et
de droite et de gauche beaucoup l'ont
dit et de gaulle a fait avec jacques rey
fait un grand plan de libéralisation de
l'économie
il faut baisser la dépense publique
parce que si on ne met pas la dépense
publique
on dit jamais où on va augmenter
augmentée vous avez entendu
les jaunes ils réclament toujours des
gens parlent plus de services publics
mais le maintien des services publics où
on coupe alors on coupe cela c'est
toujours la même pour la colonne le
liseur vous savez que le 65 ans l'âge de
la retraite au bout de cinq ans ça
procure 20 milliards d'euros d'économies
20 milliards d'euros d'économies les
doublons j'étais président département
président de région vous avez 3 à 4
milliards de doublons etc etc
et je pense que c'est que la
productivité s'il vous plaît la
productivité les entreprises tous les
jours font des gains de productivité par
rapport à leurs concurrentes
il ya un économiste qui a mesuré la
productivité de nos administrations par
rapport à nice ration en europe il ya un
écart de 10 % la voilà il faut avec le
numérique faut faire cet effort et c'est
comme ça qu'on parviendra notamment dans
les hôpitaux à m par exemple des
médecins comme des entraîneurs parlent
bien sûr bien sûr est tentant d'aller
bien mouvement de gilet jaune est
français on va toucher 76 sortir dé moi
ça m'intéresse pas de raconter des
balivernes et moi je pense que la droite
convaincra les français que si elles
parlent non pas le langage de la
démagogie
parce que franchement sur ce registre là
il y en a d'autres à l'extrême gauche et
à l'extrême droite
très bien donc moi je veux je pense
qu'il faut parler un langage de la
vérité
un langage de la raison et croyez moi
les français ont beaucoup de bon sens et
comprendront parfaitement que si on veut
améliorer leur situation
plus encore celle de leurs enfants si on
ne bouge rien on va dans le mur en tant
qu est ce que vous savez la
réincarnation de françois fillon en peau
du foie due to buy d'abord il est vivant
voilà voilà
et on est dix fois trop lille c'est
qu'on retrouve les grands décors
éléments de son probable d'ailleurs vous
d'été programme était vraiment en
position centrale sur l'écran quand je
la prends moi je lutte dont on a failli
dans l'incarnation politique comme un
but quand une tentation crew puisque
vous allez repris son parti je le disais
giallo contre une tentation
groupusculaire je ne veux pas que l air
termine je veux dire dans une salle à
l'étroit dans une cabine téléphonique et
il faut sans nom mais la politique c'est
et sondages la politique c'est de
s'élargir mais comment est-ce qu'on
s'élargit en 2d ciment par les idées et
par le haut la profondeur et l'aptitude
vous prenez le rassemblement derrière
dans votre livre est ce que c'est pas
une critique en creux della sera
gilles laurent loquet on me voyez ce que
je critique dans mon livre c'est cette
manie qu'ont à tous de personnaliser la
vie politique jusqu'à mails mâcon qui
avait intitulé d'ailleurs son parti avec
ses propres initiales vous rendez compte
jusqu'où ça peut aller bon et ça je
pense que le nom même de la droite qui a
fait passer l'homme providentiel le plus
tôt du chef avant les idées que c'est
pour vous mais vous en a il ya très
longtemps je pense à michelet juste
après l'expérience bonapartiste
s'adressant aux français à la france dé
france guéri des individus le le mal de
l'individu du culte du chef depuis qu'on
a décapité de notre roi il est profond
moi ce que je pense et ce que j'essaie
de faire c'est au moins que la droite
française est une contribution originale
on peut aimer ou pas mon bouquin mais on
me dira pas quand même qu'il ya pas d
idées un peu original voilà il est ni
totalement libérale ni totalement
conservateur je pense que nos vies
personnelles exprime ce fait la queue on
a besoin à la fois de progrès mais on a
besoin d'éléments permanence voilà un
peu dans la philosophie de
françois-xavier bellamy justement sur ce
besoin de german je suis proche de il a
écrit d'ailleurs un très beau lui je le
cite quand 2 me sur mon chapitre sud
oui le livre qui s'appelle demeure du
site quand je parle du progressisme sur
le même créneau
non c'est différent il est très vite
vous avez la même philosophie c'est à
dire que vous pensez que la reconquête
doit passer par les idées avancées par
les hommes est ce que je vais vous
trouver quelques idées à droite vous
trouvez que l'ado a beaucoup fait la
promotion de ses idées ces derniers
temps non mais juste acheteurs du coup
son score aux européennes sera un test
auprès de vos électeurs pour voir s'ils
sa philosophie la bonne ou par non mais
ça n'a rien à voir
vous savez moi ce que j'ai observé
pendant les primaires de la droite c'est
que avec un socle qui tient sur la
liberté sur l'autorité de l'état sur la
fierté française sur des valeurs vous
réunissez très franchement 75% 80% de la
droite du centre et d'un certain nombre
d'abstentionnistes c'est ce que
j'aimerais retrouver que j'aimerais
retrouver c'est cette synthèse mais sur
des convictions fortes pas des
convictions molle voilà et je pense en
plus qu'il faut remonter le pays parce
que la france continue décrocher
malheureusement est ce que vous partagez
la vision personnelle de françois xavier
bellamy sur l'île et j'ai ce débat là
c'est un débat totalement piégée
1 il n'est pas question de toucher à la
loi veil est évidemment aucun patron de
groupe ça m'intéresse un peu quand même
parce que comme parlementaires ont fait
la loi donc il n'est pas question de
toucher à cette loi maintenant dire
qu'il faut pas confondre comment
dirais-je tout et son contraire dire que
il faut aussi être vigilant pour
accompagner des femmes pour leur laisser
la liberté de choix moi je suis pour la
liberté de choix voilà dans un cadre qui
est la loi républicaine c'est tout je
vous n'êtes pas tendre avec avec vos
amis avec votre famille politique dans
ce livre vous dites à droite si les voix
parvienne à se faire entendre
elles peinent toutefois à se faire
comprendre aux discordants trop
déroutante
vous dites qu alors que la droite est la
première force d'opposition au parlement
vous n'êtes pas audible quand à être
crédible c'est une toute autre affaire
malheureusement c'est ce que vous dites
dans votre livre comment vous
l'expliquez la faute à qui non mais ya
pas de faute vous savez moi quand on est
sorti un cd deux élections
présidentielle et législatives j'avais
fait un longue interview à l'époque et
j'avais dit surtout il faut repousser
d'un an
l'élection du chef et il faut prendre un
an pour un travail de refondation on ne
l'a pas fait bon je pense qu'on a fait
là une erreur simplement pourquoi il ya
cacophonie parce que quand on a pas une
ligne qui est très déterminée qui
ensuite partagé alors petit à petit ça
avance voilà il ya un pas qui fait
électif leur avec guillaume avec
guillaume larrivé et je pense que ça
c'est fondamental mais dès lors qu'il ya
pas de ligne il ya cacophonie socama
lynch et laurent wauquiez mais il ya eu
les alors je trouvais que la ligne était
très identitaire moi je poussais pour
que l associe la liberté à l'identité je
pense qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui la ligne
beaucoup plus écolo équilibré qui a
seulement et sur l'économie que j'avais
du mal à trouver une ligne par exemple
vous parle vous parler du concours les
nîmes on note
là encore là alors la setil il faut le
dire qu'on aurait pu alors c'était alors
voilà je lis h et je dispute s'était
alors moi je peux on peut dire que larbi
c'est michel grossiord j'avais lu l'épée
nous accepter son démarrage
j'ai cru que c'est un très bon jugement
pour guillaume pelletier qui propose
d'augmenter le taux de 20%
je trouvais ce jeu de mots très bon
d'ailleurs du coup ils augmentent on
vous dit que c'est un concours d'de
absurdité économique
est-ce que avec une ligne si diverses
vous pouvez comment vous faites comment
on pouvait 30 ans dames rd 1006 diverses
au sein de votre faction cinquième
numéro 3 quand même non mais c'est pour
ça que il faut qu'on se refonde à partir
des idées
une fois qu'on aura une vraie
refondation suri alors de temps en temps
il peut y avoir une divergence chez
normal un parti ça n'est pas une caserne
non plus donc ça ça ne gêne pas mais
quand il ya des trop grand écart par
rapport à cette idée de liberté en
matière d'entreprises
là ça pose problème c'est pour ça que
encore une fois si on fait pas cet
effort parce que je pense qu'il ya un
peu de paresse intellectuelle
donc maintenant on en sort petit à petit
moi je m'en félicite
mais il ya un gros boulot à faire à ce
prix là totalement j'avais écrit pour un
non pour laurent wauquiez
ce en quoi vos dédicaces pour laurent
wauquiez je la donnerai pas grossir est
ce que ce livre on a quand même
l'impression que c'est un livre
programme un livre de propositions et
pas savoir dit il n'y a pas cette
proposition
maintenant il disait qu'il ya pas de
propositions nouvelles par rapport à la
douane il ya des propositions est ce que
ça c'est suit un homme politique qui est
prêt à prendre la tête de la droite
voire plus non non non c'est non maculé
guénon vous maculé dans le travers que
je dénonce la personnalisation j'essaie
simplement vous savez que je suis
attaché aux idées c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs même les
empêche pas l'envié mais opposants de
tout à l'heure l'ont reconnu donc voilà
j'ai c'est long j'essaie mois de peser
sur le logiciel de la droite parce que
si on ne le fait pas on risque la
disparition je vais vous dire le
problème c'est pas vraiment la droite
est ce que vraiment la france pour la
droite c'est pas vraiment l'horizon
notre horizon à nous tous c'est la
france et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
laisser et mal macron face à madame le
pen c'est ce que veut
ces skis 2022 vrai nom retail et moi je
veux que on puisse rebâtir quelque chose
une vraie alternative aux primaires à
droite en 2022 comme ça prévient j'ai
déjà répondu moi je pense que d'abord il
faut pas toucher au statut ensuite ou
bien il ya un homme ou une femme qui
s'imposent
ou quel cas c'est toujours mieux
toujours plus facile mais s'il n'y a pas
de d'hommes ou de femmes providentiels
à ce moment là bas il vaut mieux passer
à part la primaire par le peu que faire
que le premier tour élection
présidentielle de vienne a pris mais on
en reparlera donc nous retrouvions les
dégâts merci donc le livre s'appelle
refondations aux édition de
l'observatoire merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
mesdames
la semaine prochaine c'est françois de
rugy le ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire solidaire qui
sera notre raconté
transition écologique et solidaire
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
[Musique]